ANNA KATE REAGAN:
Good afternoon.
My name is Anna Kate Reagan.
I'm majoring in
American Studies,
and I'm currently a sophomore.
Our speaker today,
Robert A. Sirico,
is co-founder and president
of the Acton Institute
for the Study of
Religion and Liberty
and the pastor at Sacred Heart
of Jesus Parish and Academy.
He received his Master
of Divinity degree
from the Catholic
University of America,
following undergraduate study
at the University of Southern
California and the
University of London.
He has written for
numerous publications,
including The New York Times,
The Wall Street Journal,
Forbes, The Financial
Times, The Detroit News,
and The Washington Times.
He has been a guest on
numerous television and radio
programs on CNN, ABC, CBS,
NPR, and the BBC, among others.
A member of the Mount
Pelerin Society,
the American
Academy of Religion,
and the Philadelphia
Society, Reverend Sirico
is the author of Defending
the Free Market: The Moral
Case for a Free Economy.
Please join me in
welcoming Reverend Robert
Sirico to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT A. SIRICO: Well, it's
good to be in Jerusalem.
[LAUGHTER]
I am really so delighted
to be with you tonight.
And I have a number of students
from my parish school, Sacred
Heart Academy, over here.
There just seems to be a
nice symbience, especially
given the fact that--
oh, I'll just guess
80% of our teachers
are graduates of
Hillsdale as well.
So it's a--
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
--good product here.
When I was in seminary,
lo those many years ago,
taught by the Apostle
Paul, I think--
[LAUGHTER]
--part of our curriculum,
part of our formation
wasn't just academic.
There was that dimension to it.
But it's also pastoral.
How do you deal with people?
And part of the work that I
was assigned to do in one year
was to work with the poor.
And this meant I was at
Catholic University of America
in Washington, DC.
And we would go
and serve the poor
in the inner city of the inner
city of Washington, DC, which
meant Anacostia.
And here's how it went.
On Fridays, a seminary
buddy and myself
would go, get on the train--
subway and go to Anacostia.
And there, we met a sister,
who ran a soup kitchen
in the basement of
a Baptist church.
And she was very
entrepreneurial.
What she did was she
contacted all of the churches
in Chevy Chase and
the various areas
surrounding Washington, DC.
And so she'd write to
the Presbyterians' lady
auxiliary, or the ladies
of the Baptist group,
or the Catholic Rosary
Society, or whatever it was.
And she'd say, we need from
you 300 meals once a year.
Your ladies can make
food for 300 people,
and we will serve them.
So I imagined what went on was
that the ladies in the Holy
Rosary Society of
Chevy Chase, Maryland,
would give the recipe
to their maids.
[LAUGHTER]
And the maids would
prepare the dinner
and hand it to the chauffeurs,
who would drive it down to us
in Anacostia.
Now, I don't know that
that really happened,
but this was my Brooklyn
fantasy going on here.
And the seminarians
would arrive.
Sister said to us, now,
here's what we do here.
Your job is to set up the
tables, put out the food,
make sure it's warm, heated.
Put out the food, clean
up after you're done,
clean the whole thing up.
And remember, whosoever
will may come,
we don't ask anybody any
questions about their status,
their life, or anything.
They just come, and they
get something to eat.
And so that was the
agreement, and we did that.
And usually what would
happen is we'd set it up,
and we'd get it going.
And then we could
sit down and maybe
have a meal with people who
were there and different chores.
I remember once, I was
bundling together some garbage
and went out to put
it in the trash bin.
And I noticed that a cab pulled
up, and two ladies got out.
And they had shopping
bags with them.
And I just greeted them.
I said, hi.
She said, are we time to eat?
I said, yeah.
She said, can we get to
the front of the line,
because we have to go.
There's a sale we need to make.
[LAUGHTER]
I said, whosoever will may come.
Sure, ladies.
Come on.
So they went downstairs,
and we would work this.
And one Friday, Joe and
myself, my classmate,
were finishing up.
And we hadn't eaten
anything because the Baptist
ladies sent chili on a Friday
in lent, so good Catholic boys.
And I said, Joe, when we
get back to the seminary,
the sisters are going to
have closed down the kitchen.
So if we're going to
get something to eat,
we'd better get something
before we get home.
And I said, there's a
fish and chips place
I saw right down the street.
Maybe we can go there
and get something to eat.
And he said, OK,
we'll go do that.
So we went to the
fish and chips place.
It was after the lunch hour.
And as we walked in,
there was a man kind
of cleaning up the tables
and sweeping out things
and a young girl helping him.
And he came over to the
table and took our order.
And I noticed he passed it
through the kitchen window.
And there was a woman in there,
and she was frying up the fish.
And immediately I realized,
oh, this is a family.
And then it dawned on
me, this is a family
who lives in this neighborhood.
This is a family that lives
in this neighborhood who
run a business in
this neighborhood.
And I am their
competitor on Fridays.
[LAUGHTER]
The advantage I had
is that we didn't
have to pay for our food.
We didn't pay for the insurance.
We didn't pay any of
the salary to anybody.
Sister worked for free.
We worked for free.
No light bills,
nothing like that.
We had no problem.
This family, on Fridays,
had less customers
because we were there
doing charitable work
in their neighborhood.
And we never asked anybody who
came to us what they needed.
And I'm sitting there eating
with my seminary buddy,
and I said, Joe, a thought
has just crossed my mind.
And he said, what?
I said, we are this
guy's competitors.
We're making life more
difficult for this family
in this neighborhood.
He said, you're a heretic.
[LAUGHTER]
I said, no, no, think about it.
He said, well, what
are we supposed to do?
He was from Brooklyn, too.
(BROOKLYN ACCENT) What
are we supposed to do?
[LAUGHTER]
I said, I'm not sure.
This thought is just
occurring to me.
It's a very
uncomfortable thought,
because we have all the best
intentions in the world.
We want to help these people.
But the problem is, we
don't know these people.
We don't know the kind
of help that they need,
and we don't ask them.
We don't ask them to
contribute anything.
bring a little food.
We don't ask them
to help us set up.
to help us clean up.
We don't know
anything about them.
There's no rationing
of any sort going on
that a price system would
normally provide for.
That has always remained
a question for me.
How do we combat that?
So my topic today is to
talk about Christianity,
social justice, and poverty.
And that thought
immediately came
to my mind, the complexities
of serving people, serving
the vulnerable,
serving the poor.
You see, it's not
just good intentions.
We need something else.
If we're talking
about feeding people,
if we're talking about
people who are poor,
then we're talking
about economics.
We have to bring sound
economics to questions
of good intentions.
And if we don't, we can make a
real mess of the whole thing.
Somebody wrote a whole
book on this called Poverty
That Hurts or Kills.
So that was my seminary
experience in the soup kitchen
long before I founded
the Acton Institute.
But the Acton Institute,
in a lot of ways,
grew out of that
concern that I began
to see on many, many,
many levels, not just soup
kitchens in inner cities.
We need something more
than good intentions.
I want to talk first about
the nature of Christianity
because that's
the moral backdrop
in which a lot of people debate
these kinds of questions.
Even if it's not an
explicit religious argument,
you notice that when we
have political arguments
about the costs of education,
the cost of health care,
the questions of
shelter, and clothing,
and the well-being
of people, it all
takes place in front of the
backdrop of a moral question.
What ought we be
doing as a society?
What kind of a society
is a moral society?
What kind of a
society is a society
appropriate to human dignity?
That's really the
question that we're
facing in many, many ways.
And Christianity, in
particular-- of course,
when I say Christianity, I
mean it in its Judeo-Christian
reality because Christianity
is the younger daughter
of Judaism--
the Jewish people,
the Jewish covenant
being the inheritance
of Christianity.
And the whole anthropology, the
whole view of the human person
that comes out of
this Biblical idea--
and it's really
incredible when you
think about what
these ideas formed
and what they grew into over
a period of roughly 2,000
to 3,000 years.
In Christianity, what is the
main claim of Christianity
is that God became one of us.
He joined at a certain point in
time and entered human history,
that the eternal God
commingled with the human race
and not from outside the
world, but he broke out
of the material world
in the incarnation
when he was born in Bethlehem.
Think about what that means.
That "In the beginning
was the Word,
and the Word was with God,"
the prologue of John's Gospel,
and "the Word became flesh."
This enfleshment is
the core foundation.
It's the way in which
Christianity views
everything else about itself--
its sacraments, its
social engagement.
It has to do with the goodness
of the material world.
And in a real sense,
this is a reiteration
of the book of Genesis.
This is why, I think,
it's very important
to keep Judaism and
Christianity together.
You can't separate the two.
In the Garden of Eden, when
God created man and woman,
He created them after having
formed all things from nothing
into being and pronounced
the material world good,
and then creates man, who is a
composite of Heaven and Earth,
the dust of the ground
and the breath of life,
and then gives man and
woman, as His first words
spoken to the human race in the
Garden of Eden, the vocation.
And that vocation is
to tend the garden.
Notice, by the way--
we won't get into
environmentalism--
but notice, by the way, that it
was a garden and not a jungle.
And what's the difference?
The garden needs tending.
The human being is not
unnatural to the environment.
Some people will argue that
we're the only unnatural thing
on the planet.
Everything else needs
to be preserved,
but human life is dispensable.
But I digress.
And, yet, it informs
what we're talking about.
Because this view, both
of the Old Testament
in the Book of
Genesis, and in the New
Testament in the Doctrine
of the Incarnation,
says something about the
sanctity of the material world,
that God had an intention
for the material world
that He created.
He reiterates that intention
in the incarnation of His Son.
And what begins to happen,
what begins to unfold
is not just an idea,
an abstraction,
but an institution.
It's called the Church.
The Church confronts
society and culture,
and builds culture,
and confronts history
with the message of her Savior.
Part of this message
is the dignity
of the human person, an
anthropological vision
that each human being, from the
first moment of their existence
until their natural demise,
is the possessor of a dignity
that each person
is unrepeatable.
Each person is unique.
Each person bears the image
of God, the Imago Dei.
Each person is created in that
image of God for eternity.
That is who the human person is.
Now that idea began
to be fleshed out
in an institutional form.
And what that meant was
that when Christianity
began to confront human
beings in their vulnerability,
whether they were widows,
whether they were orphans,
whether they were profoundly
handicapped or near death,
whether they were diseased,
regardless of their race,
that the Christian would
always confront that person as
though they were
confronting Christ himself,
because Jesus said that.
"To the extent
that you do it unto
one of the least of
these, my brethren,
you have done it unto me."
So the encounter with
the poor and the mind
and the assumption of the
Church is an encounter
with Christ Himself.
And we see this not just
as a theological concept,
but we see it very early
in the Church's history.
Even right outside of the
text of the Scriptures
we begin to see it.
There was a plague that broke
out in the city of Antioch.
And there is some
historical material
related to this, where the
legion guard, the captain,
whatever he was wrote back
to Rome and said, look,
there is a plague
that's broken out.
It's spreading.
I've pulled back the troops
so that they wouldn't
get caught in the contagion.
Of course, the politicians
had already left.
[LAUGHTER]
He said, and even people's
families, even physicians,
are leaving people
because of this contagion.
But one strange
thing is happening.
There are a group of people,
this cult following Christ,
who are staying with the dying.
And they're tending to them
at risk to their own lives.
And this is just a soldier
reporting to his superiors
right there.
Of course, you remember,
in the Acts of the Apostles
in Antioch, that's
where they were called
Christians for the first time.
They're living out what
Christ did Himself.
This intuition to associate
oneself with the dying,
with the vulnerable, with
the poor, with the broken,
because of Christianity's
belief in the Incarnation,
the seriousness with
which God took history,
and culture, and
the material world,
began to form itself
into institutions, first
very small, very informal.
It would happen, oh, I think,
in the early Middle Ages
that people, when plagues would
break out or people were dying,
they would bring
them to convents.
And very often, the convents
would have some extra rooms.
And they would bring the dying.
And they say, we don't know
what to do with these people.
Medicine was very primitive.
Would you take care of them?
And so they would
receive them in,
and the sisters would
take care of them.
And in the process of
taking care of them,
they would develop
systems of sanitation,
cleaning, refreshing the
bed, keeping air circulating.
The sisters and
monks did this too.
They began also to prepare these
very primitive recipes that
were medicinals.
Today, we enjoy them.
They're called
limoncello, sambuca--
[LAUGHTER]
--chartreuse, all these
wonderful digestifs.
But these really,
all of these things
were originally medicines,
herbal medicines
to help people.
And hit and miss, they
began to work with people.
And they found some things
worked better than others.
And this was first
called hospices and then
later in more institutionalized
forms, hospitals.
The invention of hospitals
is a Christian invention.
Not only that,
but consider this,
that institutionalized
and internationalized
organized charity is the
result of Christianity because
of the organizational
system of the Church
and the various places
that the Church existed.
And the idea that charity
was done not to people
because they were
Christians, charity
was done because
we were Christians,
because we could
encounter Christ anywhere.
Human life is sacred.
These ideas came out of this
anthropology, of this cosmology
that we find in the Old
Testament and the New
Testament.
Universities come out
of this experience
if you read any of the
great historians of ideas.
Today, we are harangued
by a secular culture that
is trying to tell the
Church how to do charity
when institutionalized
charity is our invention.
And all they have
are secularized,
desiccated forms of charity
that aren't even that generous
and certainly aren't
even that effective.
And here's why.
Because what Christian charity
did in connection with the poor
was to see the person
as a whole being.
That is to say that
they were material.
They had needs.
If they were hungry, or if they
were sick, or if they tired,
or if they were whatever
it happened to be,
to tend to those material needs,
but that there was something
more than that.
They were also
transcendent beings.
They were also beings destined
for eternal relationship
with God.
They were spiritual beings.
And this holistic view of
who the human person was
gives a fuller understanding of
how to deal with that person.
In other words, to put
it a different way,
unlike secularist
forms of charity,
we don't treat people just
as though they were animals,
just as though
they were material.
When an animal is cold, you
take it in out of the cold
and put it in the barn.
When it's hungry,
you give it some hay.
When it's thirsty, you
bring it to the trough
because that's the total
existence of an animal.
It's material.
The human being
transcends the material.
They are material, but there's
something more than physical.
And because of
that, there is love.
There is bonding.
There's an
understanding that when
a person comes to us
in need, that there's
a whole context that
must be provided
and not just the material.
The material,
again, is important,
but it's not the whole thing.
And the secularist
versions that only,
when they confront
poverty, very often
in the form of a young
woman who has become
pregnant outside of marriage,
and has been kicked out
of her home, and doesn't
have a high school education,
what will the welfare state do?
It will give her an abortion, or
it will give her contraception.
It will give her food stamps.
It will give her
some counseling,
but it won't bond with her.
It can't bond with her.
And this is why Christianity
knows something,
not just about poverty,
but about the poor.
But there's something
else embedded
in the Biblical view of human
life that's very important.
And that is that the material
world is sacred and can
be the occasion
for honoring God,
and that the bearer
of the image of God
also is bound to
the world primarily
by their use of
reason, and that we
can work in this material
world so as to produce
more than we consume.
And this understanding
of humanity
is very different than the
zero-sum form of humanophobia
that we see at
the United Nations
and very often in the
halls of Congress, the fear
that if there are more
human beings on this planet
there's going to be less of
the pie for us to all eat.
It only sees the human
person as a mouth
that consumes and not also
as a mind that produces,
that is creative.
How can it be that a
man who has 10 pigs
is richer than a
man that has one,
but a man who has 10
children is seen as poorer
than a man that has one?
Now we see the human person
as the source of creativity,
that man, as St. John
Paul II once said,
"Man is man's
greatest resource."
And that to marginalize
the dignity of human life
and to see human life
or more human life,
children as a threat to
economic productivity
is a fallacy and a
dangerous one at that.
How do we counter this?
What do we do in the face of it?
We deal with people who we know.
We bond with people who
have needs and needs
that, because we know
them, we know their needs.
This, in my tradition, is called
the principle of subsidiarity.
In the Reformed tradition,
the great Reform theologian
and statesman Abraham Kuyper
called it sphere sovereignty.
Now there are
technical differences
between sphere sovereignty
and subsidiarity,
but let me articulate
to you what I know best,
that this is in the
form of subsidiarity,
what it's talking about.
It'll sound very
familiar to you.
Basically what
subsidiarity says is
that needs are best
met at the most
local level of their existence.
Political societies
of higher complexity
ought not to intervene
into lower forms of society
except in cases
of dire emergency
and even then only temporarily.
To put it simply,
needs are best met
at the most local level
of their existence.
To put it simply,
if I have a need,
I have the first
responsibility to meet my need.
But if there's some collapse in
me for some reason or another,
then it's my family's
responsibility
to respond to that need.
And if there's a collapse
there, then our extended family,
our cousins, our relatives,
maybe our neighbors, maybe
our churches, maybe other
mediating institutions
in society that are independent
of the state, all of these
need to be the first
to be permitted
to act on behalf of
those who have needs,
precisely because these
are the people who
know the people best.
They know if there's a
real need or if you're just
putting on an act.
They know what that need is, if
it's a meal, or if it's love,
or if it's counsel, or if it's
a good swift kick in the behind,
because we all have
different needs
and unless we know each other.
The real sinister thing--
in Italian, "sinistra"
means left, by the way.
[LAUGHTER]
The real "sinistra,"
the real sinister thing
here is that the welfare
state in the name of the poor
disables the poor very often.
It disincentivizes
the rest of society
to act first because
there's an intuition.
Because resources
are scarce, there's
an intuition that says,
well, if their need is going
to be met by this group
of people, or this agency,
or whatever, then I'll
go and do something else.
And look at what happens.
Society begins to fragment.
People are no longer
bound together
by bonds of concern
and love in the way
that Alexis de Tocqueville
saw when he visited the United
States and documented it in
Democracy in America, Americans
always organizing themselves
in some kind of social group
to meet various kinds of needs.
Now authentic
community is the result
of a vibrant and strict
implementation of subsidiarity.
This is the solution,
the wealth creation
of a free economy combined
with vibrant communities
of moral concern without regard
to specific denomination.
I grew up in Brooklyn, New York.
And we had as many different
religions going on,
mostly Jewish and Catholic--
OK, and a few Protestants
were over there,
but they lived in
other neighborhoods.
[LAUGHTER]
But we worked
together on projects
that we saw as
important because we
were neighbors to one another.
We had a multi-ethnic experience
without a government mandate
to have one because
we were generally
left free to form communities.
Frederic Bastiat in his
wonderful little book--
and any students here--
well, this is Hillsdale.
You probably already read it--
The Law by Frederic Bastiat.
It's online.
It'll take you an hour
and a half to read.
It's a wonderful book
because it doesn't teach you
what to think.
It teaches you how to think.
And one of the things he
talks about, fraternité--
fraternité, fraternity,
brotherhood.
One of the things
he says in that book
is, you can't force
people to be brothers.
To the extent you force them,
they're no longer brothers--
that it has to be
something that is free,
something that is
invited, something that
is compelled not by
government, but by morality.
People talk a lot about
social justice today.
It's a well-used
and abused phrase.
Let's remember that
Aristotle gives us
a very clear definition
of what justice is.
Justice is to be treated
in accord with desert.
To the extent that
there is social justice,
it is society
treating society, that
is, people,
communities of people
treating each other as
they deserve to be treated.
But let's be very clear.
Societies don't act
unless people act.
Societies can't be
informed or imbued
with either vice or virtue.
It's people who are the
vicious or virtuous.
So the extent that we're
talking about social justice,
we need to be very careful
that people aren't smuggling
into that idea the notion
of socialist justice, which
couldn't be more of an
oxymoron than anything else.
We see that historically.
We see it today in Venezuela.
We see it in North Korea.
We see it everywhere
that socialism
has been attempted in our world,
the injustice of brutal regimes
to decide for people how
their lives should go.
The real temptation in a
morally sensitive heart
is to respond to people
in the simplest way
that they know how.
Let the government do it.
The problem is, the simplest
way isn't always the moral way.
The real way to build
a society that is just,
a society that is imbued
with a sense of something
more than justice, a sense
of charity, a sense of love,
is to allow people to get to
know one another, to act freely
and to be formed by
our moral vision.
This is not an easy undertaking.
The depressing thing
is that the very people
in our society,
religious leaders
in particular and
business leaders as well,
who ought to understand
how this works very often
don't understand how this works.
To see religious leaders
abandoning their vocation
to tend to the
needs of the poor,
to tend to the needs
of Jesus Christ, who
comes to us in
distressing disguises,
and hand that over to the
government is abominable.
And for business leaders to
likewise betray their vocation
to be creative and
productive with the talents
that they have been entrusted
with and seeking the benefit
and advantages of the
state is an equal betrayal
to the clergy, who abandoned
their vocation to the state.
My friends, we need a
different kind of society.
We need a society that
understands that piety is never
a substitute for technique.
I wish I had written
that line, but I didn't.
[LAUGHTER]
It's from Etienne Gilson,
who was a philosopher.
He said, "If you want to build
the facade of a cathedral that
represents the rising of the
soul to God like Notre Dame,
you must first
understand geometry."
And then he said,
"Piety is never
a substitute for technique,
for without technique piety
is helpless to make use of
nature for the glory of God."
We need a society that is
imbued with a moral sense
and that has a high respect
for the technique of business,
a moral sense of business,
a sense of business that
is imbued with the
kind of anthropology
that I spoke of earlier.
C.S. Lewis spoke so
beautifully of this kind
of anthropological vision, this
vision of the human person,
when he said, "You have
never met a mere mortal."
In The Weight of Glory,
he wrote these lines.
"You have never
met a mere mortal.
Everyone with whom you have
ever come in contact, every shop
girl from whom you've ever
purchased anything, anyone who
you've ever had a fight with,
anyone you've ever quarreled
with, anyone you have
ever loved or hated
is either an immortal horror
or an everlasting splendor.
But you have never
met a mere mortal."
And then Lewis went
on to say these words.
"The most sacred thing
that presents itself
to our senses next
to the blessed
sacrament itself
is our neighbor."
This anthropology comes from
a Judeo-Christian vision
of how the world was formed,
how human life came to be,
and the dignity that each human
person possesses intrinsically
in their very nature.
This is the kind
of society that we
must propose against the
ideology of division and class
warfare, against the
claims of Marxism,
and socialism, and its variants.
Now we must respond
to such ideas
with the insights of someone
like Mother Teresa of Calcutta,
who once said, "We should
not judge the rich.
We do not advocate
class struggle.
We advocate class
encounter, where
the rich save the poor and
the poor save the rich."
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you, Reverend Sirico.
We now have time for Q&A.
If you have a question,
please make your way
to the microphone.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
My question is, would it be
a good idea for all people,
instead of just physicians only,
to ask themselves before taking
action, first, do no harm?
ROBERT A. SIRICO:
Not only would that
be a good idea for
everyone to do it,
it would be especially a
good idea for physicians
to do it again today,
because I understand
that's been taken out
of the Hippocratic oath.
Did you take that out of--
did you take that vow?
SPEAKER 2: First, do no harm?
ROBERT A. SIRICO: Do no harm.
SPEAKER 2: I tried to do it.
And when you think of--
ROBERT A. SIRICO: No,
but I mean as part
of the Hippocratic oath.
SPEAKER 2: No, sir.
ROBERT A. SIRICO:
Are you a physician?
SPEAKER 2: No.
ROBERT A. SIRICO: Oh, I'm sorry.
I thought you were.
[LAUGHTER]
No.
I think they have removed
that in the monostich.
But, of course, yes, first do
no harm, absolutely, absolutely.
SPEAKER 3: Should I go?
Sir, in consonance with what you
have said so very, very well,
I just want to make
a comment on a book
by Samuel Cahill, an Irishman,
who wrote the book How
the Irish Saved Civilization.
And the last sentence
in that book,
after describing all that
St. Patrick, and Colombo,
and others did to rescue
Christianity on the continent,
the last sentence is,
"The ills of our world
will not be remedied by the
Romans, that is, the soldier,
but by the saints."
ROBERT A. SIRICO:
I believe that.
And I think we need--
we just celebrated All Saints
Day on the 1st of November.
We need to all be saints.
SPEAKER 4: Hi.
My question is concerning
wealthy Christians
or specifically
Christian business
owners who have the power to
set wages and especially--
ROBERT A. SIRICO: Could you stop
right there just for a moment?
I'm going to let you finish.
SPEAKER 4: Yeah, absolutely.
ROBERT A. SIRICO:
But I think there's
an assumption that you just made
that is economically erroneous.
So you said, business owners
who have the power to set wages.
How are wages set?
Does the fat businessman
with the cigar,
and the tuxedo, and the top
hat say, we will pay them this?
SPEAKER 4: Maybe if you--
I'm sort of going to talk
about that in the question.
You want to let
me finish it or--
ROBERT A. SIRICO:
Oh, sure, go ahead.
SPEAKER 4: So I was
wondering, specifically
regarding the employees, some
of whom might be in poverty
or struggling with
costs of living,
how does a business
owner sort of navigate
the teachings of capitalism,
which would advise them
to maximize profit at all costs,
versus the teachings of Jesus
Christ, which calls us to
alleviate suffering and help
those in poverty?
ROBERT A. SIRICO: Good.
That's a good question.
Now stay there, because I want
to walk through this with you.
This is kind of like
my soup kitchen.
It's filled with the
right intentions.
It's filled with
good intentions.
But this is why I wanted to
stop you at the first point,
but now you've given me
two or three other points
to work with.
So let's walk
through this and see.
First of all, you're
concerned with people
who have marginal income,
who have difficulty
with the cost of living.
You are concerned with their
wages, which would help them
with their cost of living.
And you're concerned with the
business owner who hires people
and what he pays them.
Those things are interrelated,
intimately interrelated.
And you see that
because you say, well,
if we could raise
their income, they
could have more things
that they need in life.
But the way in which
a business owner
decides what he
charges someone is
the same competitive
principle as the wage
earner in terms of what he is
going to buy in a given store.
In other words, the
price of the good
that that wage earner
produces, the worker produces
is not arbitrarily determined.
It's determined in
context with what
the supply and the demand
of the service, or the good,
or the products to
produce the good is.
In other words, if an
employer arbitrarily
raised the wage
scale of the worker,
the worker would produce
goods and services
that would also have to increase
in order to make ends meet.
That would mean that
all the other workers
would have to go to the
market and buy those goods
and services.
Let me finish, and
then you can come back.
They would have
to buy those goods
and services at higher prices.
And they would have to
then go to their employers
and ask for more higher wages.
Now if, on the other hand, we
allowed the prices of goods
and services to exist at
the real level-- that is,
the real cost of
their production,
whether it's in terms of
payment for employees,
or the harvesting of the
resources from society,
or shipment, or advertising,
whatever else it is--
if we allow the price
structure to be free,
then we know what the
real cost of things is.
If we inflate it arbitrarily,
we distort all that.
Now, having said all
of that, we still
have people who have a
hard time making ends meet.
How are we going to
solve that problem?
We're going to
solve that problem
by creating as productive and
as wealthy a society as we can,
where people who are wealthy
can both hire people, but also
give to those people with
the profits that they have.
So it's all interrelated.
And if we pull or obfuscate
any one part of it,
we throw the whole thing
out of coordination.
And then what ends up
happening is Venezuela,
is the Soviet Union,
where you have
an oversupply of things
that nobody wants
and an undersupply of things
that people desperately want.
Go ahead.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 4: Thank you
for the response.
But I sort of
disagree with the--
I said, thank you
for the response.
But I sort of disagree
with the premise,
so maybe a concrete
example would help.
So imagine I'm a
business owner--
I'll use round numbers--
with 50 employees, who
make $20,000 per year each,
which is a poverty wage.
And that business profits
me, say, $500,000 per year.
I could make the
decision to forego
a certain amount of that
profit, say, $250,000,
and pay each of my workers
$5,000 more per year,
which would alleviate a
lot of their suffering.
Do you think-- how do
you see that problem?
What would you advocate
for a business owner to do?
And that wouldn't raise
the cost of the commodity.
ROBERT A. SIRICO: OK.
Mr. Business Owner,
let me ask you this.
Do you have any ambitions
to grow your business?
And what portion of
that-- how much did you
say you were making, $500,000?
SPEAKER 4: Yeah.
ROBERT A. SIRICO:
What portion of that
are you spending on your
boats, and your cars,
and your rings versus
reinvesting in your business?
Or let me ask you
a simpler question.
What is the average
profit of any given
business in this country?
You don't have to be
exact, but give me an idea.
Give me a general idea because--
what's your
percentage of profit?
In that $500,000, what's the
percentage of your profit?
SPEAKER 4: I have no clue.
Do you have any idea?
ROBERT A. SIRICO:
Yeah, about 2%.
I'd invest in a company for 2%.
Yeah.
It's 2%, 3%.
We've got some economists
here who could spit this off
very easily.
It's not what you think it is.
This, by the way--
I didn't say this here,
but you read my book--
I was on the left for a number
of years when I was in my 20s.
I worked with Jane
Fonda and Tom Hayden
in the Campaign for
Economic Democracy.
[BOOS]
Come on, it's my past.
I've repented.
[LAUGHTER]
I've gone to confession.
They still want me
to do the penance.
[LAUGHTER]
And when I was
talking with somebody,
the thing he said to
me that shocked me
was, what do the richest people
do with all of their money?
I said, well, they have
boats, and they have rings.
They have cars.
He said, no, the vast
majority of that money
is invested in business.
So what I'm suggesting
to you, if you really
were that businessperson,
taking half of your profits
would mean you'd cut your
growth of your business
by half, which means your goods
and services that you provide
to the market in
general would go up
and your employees would lessen.
In other words, you wouldn't
be able to hire more.
You wouldn't be able
to hire their cousins
and their relatives.
Is that-- OK.
I'd like to continue, but
we've got other people.
We can talk afterwards.
SPEAKER 5: Thank you.
What you were saying
earlier was basically
to put on the mind
of Christ, which
is really hard to do every day.
Could you give us--
ROBERT A. SIRICO:
Tell me about it.
[LAUGHTER]
I go to confession
every other week.
SPEAKER 5: Yeah.
Anyway, I wonder if you
could give us some examples,
although you did say that doing
the work at the localest level
is the best way to meet
the needs of the people
and get to know the people
and what their needs are.
But could you give
us some examples
of some organizations that
do it right, that do it best?
What are some good
models for us?
ROBERT A. SIRICO: I will.
But let me just clear
up one assumption
that people always have.
And here's my real
heresy coming out now.
Here, this is the big one.
[LAUGHTER]
Poverty is not
solved by charity.
Charity needs to
exist in extreme cases
when there is a dire
need and whatever.
Poverty is solved not
by charity, not by even
the best charities,
but by business,
the expansion of business,
the globalization of business.
The world has risen in the last
150, 200 years out of poverty
at an astounding rate.
You've seen this.
This is Hillsdale.
You've seen the
hockey stick, right?
You've seen how most people
throughout all of history
lived at that level.
And then about 150 years
ago, it began to go up,
and up, and up, and shoot
right through the roof.
And what accounts for
that is not charity.
It's business.
Business provides jobs.
The great rabbi-- was a
medieval or Renaissance rabbi--
Maimonides had this ladder of
charity, how to help people.
And the top two
levels are give--
the most moral thing
is give anonymously.
And then the top level
is render a person--
render a person without
need of your charity.
Business well done is
the most charitable thing
that we can do.
Now, having said
that, there are tons
of charitable organizations
in the United States.
I think Salvation Army
is a good example.
In my parish, we take up a
second collection every week,
and that money goes to
the poor, by which we
mean we have a group of about
20 people in our parish.
And it's bound by our geography,
so we don't send this money
all over the world.
It's just people
we can get to know,
and it's very leveraged giving.
So if it's a working family
where the car is broken down,
we repair the car.
If it's a family
about to get evicted
for one reason or another,
we put the deposit down
on the thing.
And these people get
to know those people.
And we invite them
to come to church.
They don't have
And I've seen a few
people show up in church.
Sometimes we'll help them with
adoption questions or child
care questions and
things like that.
So it's not brain surgery.
It's just really
getting to know people.
But there are great
organizations.
I can give you a list of them.
SPEAKER 6: So you were
talking earlier about
how both a free market
framework of business and also
a local attempt to
give charity is always
going to be superior to
a top-down government
institution.
ROBERT A. SIRICO:
Almost always, yeah.
I mean, I'd be interested to
hear an example where it isn't.
SPEAKER 6: No, I
completely agree with that.
That seems entirely true.
But in the world
around us right now,
there is definitely an
increasing encroachment
of the massive, top-down
institutional government
structures that you
were talking about.
And even more than
that, it seems
like they have a very
different, almost antithetical
anthropology of what
the human person is
that's completely different.
They have completely
different ideas
of what the human good is.
And despite a lot of
outspoken voices against it,
especially recently,
it seems like it's
growing at a very rapid pace.
So on the ground, what
are some practical tools
that you suggest for
fighting this thing?
It doesn't seem like it's
slowing down at all right now.
ROBERT A. SIRICO: Yeah.
Well, I would make
two observations.
The crisis is horrendous.
People don't understand
who they are.
They just really don't
understand who they are.
If you don't believe me, I
give you drag queen story time.
I mean, this is just people--
and I don't mean
just the drag queens.
Leave them alone.
I mean the parents who bring
the kids to these things.
There is a deep anthropological
insanity in our society.
Now that's the bad side.
The good side is it can't last.
But there's another bad side.
It can last long enough
to do a lot of damage.
What is the solution to that?
Hillsdale College, Sacred
Heart Academy, the academies,
the schools, the
homeschooling parents,
the other kinds of
colleges like Hillsdale,
all of these little
platoons, these little groups
of people who still assure
one another we're not nuts.
[LAUGHTER]
They're nuts.
[APPLAUSE]
And we have to build
the wreck again.
We have to build up from it.
But we are advantaged
in the sense
that at least we
know some things.
I mean, at least Adam
Smith wrote his book,
The Wealth of Nations.
We know how this thing works.
So hopefully the collapse
won't be as deep,
although it frightens me.
Here's what frightens me.
And if I offend anybody
here, I can live with that.
[LAUGHTER]
No, but seriously,
what's frightening me
is that some
conservatives are becoming
very enamored with statist
solutions to things.
Power tends to corrupt,
and absolute power
corrupts absolutely.
And I don't care whether
that's right wing or left wing.
It's the power you
have to worry about,
when people get power and
don't let go of power,
when there isn't a
dispersion of power,
kind of subsidiarity.
And, remember, businesspeople--
and to my colleague, my friend
there who was talking, I am
not canonizing businesspeople
as such any more than I'm going
to canonize the poor as such.
There are businesspeople
who are greedy
and who make deals with
people who can make deals.
Nobody comes to me.
I never get a lobbyist.
[LAUGHTER]
They never come to me.
Now ask yourself why I
don't hear from lobbyists.
Because I don't have
political power.
That's why.
Crony capitalism is
antithetical to real capitalism
or at least to
real free markets.
Let's use that word,
because I don't
like the word "capitalism."
So these are the things.
All of this can be
solved by right ideas.
And so institutions
like this are the place
to promote those right ideas
and the family, of course.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 7: Thank you
so much for your talk.
It was really beautiful.
This question might
be a little bit silly,
given some of your last answers.
But given your focus on local
institutions and things,
would you see distributism as
a viable answer to the welfare
state?
ROBERT A. SIRICO: No, I don't.
I think distributism--
for those of you
who don't know what
it is, it sees itself
as a third way between
capitalism and socialism.
And the articulations, the
best articulations, I suppose,
of distributism come
from G.K. Chesterton,
who wrote remarkably little
on the subject, and Belloc.
And there are a
few other writers,
but these are the chief
writers that people
have reference to today.
I think distributism,
to the extent that it
is most cogent and persuasive,
is not an economic theory.
It's an aesthetic theory.
It tells us that we
can't be mechanized.
We can't be subordinated
to just systems, that we
have to be personal,
and creative,
and cultivate authenticity.
But that's not an
economic system.
I think if we put in place
tomorrow a real distributist
model, even an ideal model
to the extent that Chesterton
has any practical models--
which I don't think
he really does--
I think we would have mass
starvation in the world.
Because we need
international corporations.
We need large,
global industries--
not industries that are bribing
governments or being subsidized
by governments, but
we need coordination
internationally through a market
pricing, a free pricing system.
And distributism
wouldn't allow for that.
It would make everything small.
Small is beautiful, according
to the distributists.
And we have too big a world.
With more than six billion
people on the planet,
we need big solutions
to problems.
We don't need microloans.
We need macro loans.
We need big industries.
And I think that can be done
in a moral way that can also
have an aesthetic
that can critique
the kind of soulless
business that the aesthetics
of distributism
seek to criticize.
SPEAKER 1: We have time
for one more question.
SPEAKER 8: Thank you.
ROBERT A. SIRICO: We're
having so much fun.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 8: It seems
to me that there
is one word at the
core of any religion
or at the core of
nature, describes it,
and that is transformation.
We are asked to
transform ourselves,
but not to transform others.
We can help others to
transform themselves.
That is what you seem
to be laying out.
Am I close?
ROBERT A. SIRICO: You're close.
You know who put it very well?
Let me see if I can
get this quote right,
because this is
one of these quotes
that I always manage to garble.
Winston Churchill said that,
"The socialism of Christianity
said--" no.
"The socialism of today says,
whatever is yours is mine.
And the socialism of
Christianity said,
whatever is mine is yours."
It's voluntary.
That's the secret
of the socialism--
if you want to use that
word, which is anomalous,
because it's not socialist.
It's this sense of
sharing and cooperation.
So I think that's what you were
saying, this transformation.
Thank you very much for
your time, a pleasure
being with you.
[APPLAUSE]